akk do you like trigonometry yes do you
like live shows yes then you're going to
love the next trigonometry live show on
the 2nd of november at the leicester
square theatre in london it'll be with
one of our all-time favorite guests
peter hitchens this is very exciting
news i will make sure to take out an
advertisement in pravda tomorrow a fleet
of sponsored ladders will descend on the
kremlin to promote this wonderful event
our great and powerful leader uncle vlad
will be wearing sponsored trigonometry
speedos on white horse no nice mate our
first show with andrew doyle is now
completely sold out and this one will
sell out just as quickly tickets are
strictly limited and they're selling
like copies of the communist manifesto
greatest book in the world second only
to 10 cute things you didn't know about
joseph stalin i love that buzzfeed
article anyway see you there guys
hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitten and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people it
does not get any more fascinating than
the two brilliant guests returning
guests to the show that we have for you
today they are of course evolutionary
biologists heather hying and brett
weinstein who are here with us to talk
about a brilliant fantastic book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century we cannot wait to speak with
them the show is going to work like this
very simple we're going to chat with
brian and heather for about an hour an
hour and 10 minutes we're going to have
a very short break and then after that
it's going to be your chance to put
questions to brett and heather if you
want to have that all you need to do is
send us a super chat on youtube or send
us a paypal the link to that is in the
comment section below this video well
and without any further ado let's
welcome brett and heather in here let's
get the conversation started guys
welcome back
gentlemen
thank you for having us both it's good
to be here oh good to have you back i
tweeted about this and i genuinely meant
to i've been like a kid on christmas
morning all day today because we can't
wait to speak with you the book is
absolutely fantastic i really recommend
everybody read it and let's let's get
straight into of course in the book you
talk about evolution the some of the
adaptations both physically and
genetically and culturally that we've
seen and you talk about how that how
that is compatible or not quite
compatible with the modern world but i
think before we get into some of that
detail the underlying theme of the book
that i kept having in the back of my
head as i was reading it was that
facebook slogan of move fast and break
things and and my sense was what you're
really saying is as a western industrial
civilization we've moved so fast and
broken so many things that many of the
things you talk about in the book
whether it's advice on food advice on
sleep advice on parenting advice on
dating in all of those areas we're not
no longer living in ways that are
actually healthy for us
well move fast and break things might
make sense if you did it well
unfortunately the way we have done it
has caused us not to stop doing the
things that are broken rather than to
learn from them and prototype our way to
a better future and so yes that is one
of the themes of the book is that we are
now
living in uncharted territory that is so
different from what we are evolved to
deal with that we are simply incapable
of adapting fast enough to keep up
yeah and the uh the idea that move fast
and break things is the rule you should
abide by or the rule you shouldn't abide
by is part of the problem right move
fast and br and be willing to break your
arm perhaps as a way to know how to
navigate risk in the world okay
move fast and be willing to break your
head no like don't do that that's not a
good choice for a human being it's not
going to end well for you so um part of
i think you're right i think that is one
of the themes of the book and part of it
too is trade-offs in everything right it
is there are there will be
no or almost no static rules with which
we can live our lives we need to
understand that we are evolving changing
complex beings and so need strategies
that uh adapt with the times and with us
and one of the rules you talked about in
the book and is something that i think
we're seeing more and more in our
society is avoiding uh simple solutions
to incredibly complex problems
well in some sense you want solutions to
be as simple as possible but the idea
that you should uh you know kid yourself
that the solution will be simple you're
not entitled to a simple solution to a
complex problem especially if you
haven't even really understood what the
problem is so very frequently what we'll
do is we'll identify a symptom as if it
was a problem and then we'll try to
treat that symptom and we'll create a
proliferation of even further symptoms
rather than looking for the root cause
and figuring out how to solve it once
and for all yeah so
go for it just please go one of the
other themes which is um exactly what
you francis are alluding to here with
the question is um the problem of
reductionism that you know sometimes
simple solutions are the right ones um
but far too often as brett points out
and as we do repeatedly throughout the
book as soon as you have something that
you've measured you mistake that for the
thing that needed to be measured and the
only thing that needed to be measured
and so now we've got a number we've got
a thing to point to that
may or may not be the key symptom of the
of the broken system in question
but we lose our motivation to keep
looking for more things when we have a
number in hand and so sometimes a simple
solution will be will be the right one
but very often it's not and we need to
keep our brains
alive and our eyes open to continue to
look for the deeper truths
and heather very much to your point
that's actually what i was going to ask
you about it might sound to someone who
hasn't yet read the book but we're
talking an abstract here very much so
can you put some flesh on those bones
for people what are some of the examples
of of the reductionism the scientism
that you all should talk about in the
book uh that i think you're alluding to
that yeah well um one example
is uh the idea that the appendix
is a vestigial organ and
um you know almost everyone who lives in
the weird you know that acronym western
educated industrialized rich democratic
world knows someone uh who has had a
run-in with appendicitis and in some
cases it's been you know close to deadly
usually people don't die anymore but
only if you live close to
a medical facility and so the story that
we've been handed for decades now is
this organ has no function for us is all
cost and so it is incumbent upon us to
surgically remove it at first sign of
disease
well that story doesn't hold up from an
evolutionary perspective because we've
only been living in this post-industrial
world for 150 years call it and the idea
that um that this organ has been just
killing people off
for all of this time for you know for
however long it is that people imagine
it to have been vestigial uh
forgets the power of selection so
selection would have begun to produce
this this organ had it had it been
entirely non-functional as it turns out
the fact of the disease in a pe in the
appendix is a result of our modern
lifestyles and we know that because when
we look at non-weird cultures non-weird
peoples the rate of appendicitis is
almost zero
and in fact it may actually be zero i
don't remember the numbers um but what
you do have is an emerging story about
what the value is that in those cultures
where our where the food is not quite so
sterile not quite so clean for our guts
and for those people who have more
frequent bouts of gi distress and gi
illness the appendix effectively acts as
a repository for good bacteria with
which it repopulates the gut after such
bouts so in the weird world where our
appendix doesn't get used much because
our food is so clean um and you know
probably too clean
uh the appendix becomes inflamed because
it's not used so it is becoming in our
very very modern circumstances uh a
hazard but it is still not a hazard in
most of the world where people don't
live like we do the the error in
thinking was at looking at this and
because we couldn't identify the value
of the appendix assuming it didn't have
one rather than saying we can see that
it obviously must have one not only does
the organ itself have some expense in
building it but the cost of the risk
that comes from having one is
substantial enough that the pressure to
eliminate it would have been
overwhelming
it's also true that phylogenetically
doesn't make sense that it would be an
organ in the process of disappearing
because our relatives that would have to
have it in order for that story to be
true do not so
it was i spotted in fact in college the
idea that the appendix had to have a
purpose that we hadn't identified that
the vestigial story was simply wrong but
it was decades before anybody figured
out a story that was satisfying as to
what it did and we have to get
comfortable with that we are new to
biology in a way that we are not to
physics and chemistry and that means
that very frequently although we can say
something about how a system works we
don't understand it well enough to be
authoritative and we have to be patient
to figure out what all of the details
are in order to see the full story
yeah go for ahead of the place let me
just add one more thing to that which is
um we we invoke in the book the concept
uh introduced by gk chesterton of
chesterton's fence right
uh in which two people walking down a
road run into a fence and it's in their
way and one of them says let's get rid
of it and the second one the more wise
one says there's no way that we should
get rid of it until then unless we can
identify what its function is supposed
to be at which point then we can talk
about it but until you know what its
function is or was supposed to be
there's no way that you should just get
rid of it and so we we raised that early
in the book this this parable of
chesterton's which has come to be known
as chesterton's fence and we basically
say look for
other things in the world like this so
chesterton's appendix chesterton's
breast milk chesterton's play
chesterton's gods right there are many
things that we moderns are foregoing
because it feels to us like we're done
with that we're mature we've we've
evolved beyond it we are moderns we
don't need that thing anymore and too
often we get rid of things that still
have function or are tied to things with
function and we do so because we haven't
actually stopped to try to figure out
what the function might be
don't you think that that actually shows
that we're arrogant as a culture we're
arrogant as a society that we look at
things and because we can't understand
them or we don't find a purpose for them
therefore we dismiss them
absolutely yes yes we are and i think
you know i think people in many cultures
have an arrogance to them but it is
um it is symptomatic of too many of the
systems that have the power to drive
narrative in weird cultures the
arrogance is is lauded rather than
skepticism being lauded too often and we
see this in evolutionary biology in
particular where there has been
incredible resistance to the idea that
religious traditions are in some way
meaningful and important right they've
been dismissed as mind viruses which
they obviously aren't right they're just
as adaptive as a wing or an eye or any
other structure
and the reason that we've done that is
because in some sense they are not
literally true but the fact that they
are not literally true shouldn't
persuade us of anything one way or the
other what they ought to be is just like
a wing or an eye they ought to be
functional right functional belief
systems are ones that give you an
advantage and that doesn't necessarily
come from them being
literal and analytic
so yes there is an arrogance and it is
something we will think more clearly
when we get past it and we realize just
how early we are in the study of
adaptive complex systems
well you've both preempted my question
there which is kind of the spiritual
appendix of religion as you were talking
about the appendix i was thinking about
this so is it like the appendix in that
in a weird culture we don't actually
need it and it's actually potentially a
source of inflammation and harm or is it
that we've just taken away something out
of our societies without really fully
appreciating the value that it still has
for us it is both to the tenth power and
that's the problem um because
what we have is a compendium of wisdom
matched to past environments and it's
chesterton's fence after chesterton's
fence there are structures in there that
are still serving their original purpose
and are vitally important there are
other structures in there that may not
only be useless they can actually be
harmful in our current environment and
the process of sorting which is wheat
and which is chaff is going to be a very
difficult one but what we can say for
sure is that it starts with the
recognition that those belief systems
were adaptive that doesn't necessarily
mean they were good there were lots of
things that urged people to war things
we mustn't do again
uh that you know were adapted right so
what does adaptive mean for people who
are not evolutionary biologists what
adaptive means is that uh they are the
product of selection and they enhance
the chances that the creature that has
these traits will have their genes
lodged in the future
it does not mean good
right to say something but to say that
something is adaptive does not mean that
you are saying that it is good either
for you the individual or the population
in which that adaptive trait may be
spreading uh goodness is a moral
assessment and uh we you know we say
early in the book as we always did in
our classrooms as well um that we will
not fall prey to you know the
naturalistic fallacy the is out fallacy
there are sort of a cluster of similar
fallacies that philosophers recognize
but um to recognize that something is is
natural which is itself a
a complicated term but to recognize that
something is evolutionary is not the
same thing as recognizing as claiming
that it is what should be and you know
that in fact is the error
that um people who have abused
evolutionary thinking have made people
like social darwinists and eugenicists
and such have made exactly that error
they have seen some measure of success
and have decided that that thing that
has succeeded in the way that they have
claimed it is therefore who should be
winning and there is nothing in
evolutionary thinking actually that that
suggests that it's also important for
people who are bootstrapping a model for
thinking about evolution to realize that
you have competing strategies in which
both versions or the multiplicity of
versions are all products of selection
so ruthlessness is certainly a product
of selection as is compassion
rape is a product of selection as are
laws that punish people who rape right
these are competing strategies and what
that in part does is it puts the onus on
us to figure out which parts of what is
evolutionary we wish to retain and
augment and which one which ones we wish
to to banish and it's it's really a
human question it can't be solved simply
by science for exactly the reason that
heather is pointing out the fact that
something is isn't the same as it uh it
being a good thing
and uh choosing is is our obligation
bret before i interrupted you to ask you
to explain adaptive to us and our
audience you were talking about religion
being an adaptive thing what does that
mean for us
well it means a number of things one as
long as scientific folks keep wagging
their finger at religious folks and
saying you're suffering from a delusion
we're never going to get anywhere
because religious folks know that
they're not suffering from a delusion
which doesn't mean that what they
believe in is literal or even still
relevant
right we have to get to a conversation
in which the scientific folks
acknowledge what religion has been and
why it has characterized every
important society
and the
the religious folks recognize that their
book of wisdom may in fact be so out of
date that it needs a
rethinking beyond
the style of rethinking that has
typically characterized religion right
we could it would annoy many people but
we could draw a phylogeny of religions
and you could see that you know
christianity is a version of judaism and
that protestantism is a version of
christianity and we could you know
increasingly divide these things those
are competing
programs for exploiting habitats some of
them are
adapted to different places and times
and you know it works in an evolutionary
fashion for a reason sectarian
difference is effectively
like variation in a population of
creatures in which those variants that
more efficiently exploit the landscape
and frustrate competition uh between
members of the same lineage prosper and
those that fail to do those things go
extinct that's how these things got
shaped by selection and it's why we have
these remarkable narratives in the
present but
uh to recognize that these are products
of evolution is to say that we know that
they are adapted to the environments
from which they came and not the
environments that we find them in and
that puts the onus on us to figure out
which portion of these things is still
relevant and which portion needs an
update or replacement
the the part of the book that i found
really interesting was where you tackled
astrology because now we're very
dismissive of people who enjoy astrology
but you were you in fact said look hang
on there is merit behind
this way of thinking
yeah which will sound astounding
with just that introduction and indeed
it did
it did to us when we first began
thinking about this
the fact is that modern astrology is
generally bunk because it asks only
um what day you were born and then
imagines uh that it can tell you a whole
lot of things about your adult
personality as a result i think
if my understanding of most modern
astrology is right
but we cite in the book a study
that looks at
birth month
at
gosh i think it's
maybe even over a million
records from a hospital in the new york
area
uh over 80 or 90 years
separates these births by month and then
does this longitudinal analysis of
tens dozens maybe over a hundred
different maladies that afflict human
beings and asks the question before
doing the analysis
do maladies that people have an
adulthood are they predicted
by the month in which they were born the
thinking behind this being
um
by the month in which they were born but
remember that the difference here
between this and most modern astrology
is that the control is the place all of
these people were born in the same place
and so
if you were born in new york in december
are you not likely to be exposed to
different pathogens and different
early experiences than if you're born in
new york in june that is the reason that
we can begin to expect and that these
researchers predicted and that they
indeed found that there are indeed
disease differences by birth month if
and only if you keep track of where you
were born so most modern astrology
doesn't do that and there's no reason to
think that it has any predictive power
at all really completely not but
if you include if you include place and
and birth month more or less and we have
evidence that disease physical disease
varies by birth month when you control
for place well behavior might as well
because just as you might be
have more access to the outside and to
exploring if you're born in one month
versus another
and thus get different exposures to
disease you might also be differently
differently
have different tendencies to be
socializing or to you know be inward
focused versus extroverted so i want to
clear this up a little bit because i i
can almost hear our haters cracking the
champagne opening
the point is an ancestral version of
astrology in which a person that was
resident in a location was analyzing
other people resident in those same
locations and noticing that the moment
in the year at which you were born might
have impact on your temperament or other
parameters of your life that person
might have had predictive power having
nothing to do with the content of the
stories they would tell about why you
were that way but just the simple fact
of somebody born in october meets a
certain
sequence in their nutrition in the
pathogens that they encounter etc so
modern astrology because it doesn't pay
attention to where you were born is bunk
it's nonsense it's a con
but the point is that doesn't mean
ancestral astrology was ancestral
astrology would have been a metaphorical
explanation for patterns that could not
have been described in analytical terms
and it is of course in principle
possible for somebody to resurrect such
a tradition at any time
interesting though one thing you just
said i think gives even more reason to
imagine that ancestral astrology will
would have been more predictive than
modern astrology even if you do control
for where you're born which is that at
least in the weird world our diet
doesn't tend to differ much over the
year even those of us who buy at farmers
markets and try to eat seasonal produce
we all have plenty of food to eat
throughout the year pretty much and so
the the pattern pre-industrially and
certainly pre-agriculturally of boom and
bust cycles in just simply available of
food and also available of particular
macronutrients might have specifically
exaggerated predictions
exaggerated the patterns around which
you could have predicted differences um
that would have come from when you were
born i also think uh you know it
bears analogy to the relationship
between um
why am i blanking on the term alchemy
and chemistry right a lot of modern
chemistry emerges from the wrong-headed
attempt to create gold out of other
things right a problem that is
fundamentally nuclear and therefore not
within the realm of chemistry which is
about electric charge primarily
but the point is the study was
productive just as somebody who didn't
have the tools to look into
your pathogens because they existed
before the term theory of disease and
didn't have tools they could even find
such things
might have noticed patterns
uh you know that the stories that they
told about it
may have been useful and our modern
understanding of oh uh you know we have
a cyclic pattern of disease through the
year and it may have impacts on uh on
development you know there's now a
legitimate scientific study of this
which has more or less displaced the the
prior version
um but anyway and you know many things
are like this you don't necessarily know
what you're looking for when you set
about study and you may tell yourself
wrong stories it may be that acupuncture
works for
reasons we don't yet know but she is a
myth you know very likely that it is
um anyway
but
the the thing that you also talked about
in the book is how important myths are
in a way that we don't understand and in
a way and how it bound us together in
our societies
well not only are they important i mean
you know
we sometimes drive our colleagues crazy
because our scientific cause imagine
my colleagues love to imagine that they
have no faith and that they are
trafficking in
facts not myth but this is not how
science progresses a you need to have at
least a little bit of faith in order to
do science right the idea is to minimize
the amount but it can't be zero right
because you don't even know for sure
that you exist that you're not in
someone else's experiment being fed data
in order to see what your mind will do
with it right you can't prove that
you're not there so you assume it you
have faith that you actually do exist
and you can observe the universe and do
science yeah it's not useful to spend
time worrying about that right you can
either spend your entire life on that
one puzzle and never get anywhere or you
can say i'm gonna just take that one on
faith and i'm gonna work on things that
might matter and go forward but as we
build a model of the universe
scientifically
there are zones that we understand
really well and then there are giant
gaps we can't fill in yet and very often
as you get from a zone you know well
towards a gap you don't know anything
about at all you become increasingly
metaphorical in the way you describe
things so you know atoms as billiard
balls right we know that atoms are not
billiard ball like now but we didn't and
thinking that they were billiard ball
like was good enough for a while it
allowed us to do certain things and not
others so the basic point is any system
of comprehension involves a whole lot of
myth and yes there is value in trying to
minimize the amount that's dependent on
myth because those myths can can steer
you wrong right you don't necessarily
know what's contingent on what when it's
told in some narrative form
but
but anyway science contains myth the
idea is to get rid of that myth we're
nowhere near near doing that fully yet
and we ought to just accept it that you
know though it's not like there are the
myth people and the fact people it's we
all have a good deal of myth in our in
our models i guess it's also true though
that um
even those of us who are highly
analytical
also take in information through
narrative
and many people vastly prefer the
narrative route for taking information
whether or not they they recognize that
and
since we are a narrative species
using myth to reveal truths
even if they come via stories that are
as we say literally false but
metaphorically true
is likely to be a better way to
encapsulate those so that we retain them
and we can use them going forward most
people will remember a story better than
a graph
it's very yeah it's it's a very powerful
way of putting it most people do
remember as stories it's the way we're
built the part of the book that i found
very very interesting is where
if i say so myself you flirted a little
bit with social conservatism when
talking about sex
and reproduction um
yeah well it's not really social
conservatism well i i don't know i don't
know what to say i would say that there
are
social conservatism which are actually
correct and that the idea you know a
libertarian
view of sex does not appear to be making
people happy it does not appear to be
making civilization more functional it
appears to be isolating people from each
other causing people to be taken
advantage of increasing sexual violence
and normalizing it so
uh yeah there's a lot wrong with the way
people are engaging but what i think is
maybe a little bit subtle
is that
this is a sex positive position it is
not sex positive as that term is
typically used but the idea is if you
recognize what an important and valuable
gift sex is and it's an evolutionary
gift right evolution actually turned us
into one of very few species that has
sex for pleasure right that was not a
modern invention that was not us
rebelling against our biology that was
our biology awarding us an incredibly
valuable tool for bonding
and in so doing it uh gave us a
responsibility which we are treating
terribly right we are not recognizing
how marvelous it is that we were given
that gift and then we gave ourselves a
gift in the form of birth control which
allowed us to control even more and what
we started doing is treating it
frivolously like a recreational
activity right and i'm not saying it
shouldn't be fun it should be
tremendously rewarding but
you know but the point is when people
think if sex is good then
easy access to sex must be great right
when they think that they're thinking
something incorrect and the proof is all
around us yeah and when you say the
proof is all around us what what do you
guys mean i'm sorry to jump in heather
but what are you guys talking about
surely come on everybody's having sex
that's brilliant people just get you
know get together they hook up they
isn't isn't that the liberal brilliance
of the modern society that we've all
been striving for to to free women from
the risk of sex and and now we're all
liberated and everything is wonderful
never heard you use those words mate no
no i don't i don't actually agree with
them obviously as you know but
yeah everyone is sexually satisfied now
right
just listen to them talk and you'll know
that's it right there and um at the
point that everyone is so clearly not
sexually satisfied what do we do we
double down and double down double down
okay
let's push more junk sex in your face at
all moments make it apparently available
to everyone
um at any time they want it and let's
see what happens well we're just getting
more dissatisfied and and more and more
and more so
um you know
there is also a problem with imagining
that it is i mean of all things to
imagine that this should be a matter of
personal individual agency sex seems
like a particularly strange choice you
know we know it was an error to go
towards junk food over in food space but
at least you're only poisoning your own
body
to go towards junk sex when sex is
explicitly relational when it's
explicitly about two people about two
people coming together and exploring
each other in a more deep and intimate
way than you know than any other way
that we know to imagine that that's that
that can be driven by the market
effectively and that what's in my head
because i saw pictures of some video of
someone doing something over here to
someone not related to you i'm going to
bring that into my into my you know
bedroom with you and it's going to be
good that there's no relationship to
anything that is rewarding or satisfying
you know is it is it physically
titillating can you actually can you get
off yeah okay but that's it then it's
over just like junk food the pleasure is
very quick and ends quickly and then
you're left with an abyss afterwards
right you you don't you don't end up
with the reward that lasts a long time
whereas you do with non-junk food and
with non-junk sex with non-junk music
and non-junk everything right we can we
can
we can reward ourselves by training
ourselves
just as those who have weaned themselves
off fast food into enjoying a delicious
and nutritious diet into
being rewarded by you know sexual
pleasure that is wildly sex positive but
that isn't about having your head turned
and you know chasing down every
hot thing that you see
so and i just want to add to this i
think it is important people who've read
the book will know that we argue that
men have two reproductive strategies and
women have one
um the two reaper i mean we divide it
into three because you know
rape is a strategy that works it's one
that hopefully we can drive to something
like zero but
there's
generally speaking a no
investment strategy where a male behaves
in a way that in the past would have
impregnated a female and walks away so
and go as one of my students uh called
it
um
and then there's a strategy in which
males invest in a partner and that
partner's offspring right and when men
are in that mindset they are not the
same as women they have different values
but they are
similar to women in their level of
choosiness and discernment and so what
we effectively have
is a modern culture
in which we are
getting men to default to their worst
mode their non-investment mode and then
getting women to mirror that behavior
and it's not making men or women happy
that's the problem is that we have a
better mode and we are defaulting away
from it there were um there were
certainly some problems with first and
second wave feminism i always called
myself a feminist
even though i came of age really as
third wave feminism was was happening
and
it didn't look like it could possibly
become ascendant the way it did so i you
know in my younger years would call the
third wave who identified themselves as
a third wave feminist the faux feminists
the fake feminists because it looks
illiberal it looks you know it's it
looks frankly kind of misogynistic and
regressive and it's going to send not
just women but all of us backwards so
um this this feels consistent with a an
actually liberal perspective on
bringing equality of opportunity to men
and women equally but not pretending
that we're the same because we're not
and
one of the parts of the book that i
found really interesting in this chapter
was talking about how a society where
there was
less relationships where we were less
monogamous encourages male violence
yeah it uh it directly does because for
reasons we don't have to go into sex
race sex ratios tend to be about even at
birth and so what happens is if you have
a system in which some men sorry which
just means that there are an equal
number of boys and girls born absent
other considerations so any system that
causes some men to have more than one
wife leaves other men sidelined and one
doesn't have to extrapolate very far to
see that a bunch of sexually frustrated
men either becomes a problem internal to
a society or it becomes a global problem
when the elites who have more than one
wife take all of those sexually
frustrated young men arm them and point
them over a border at some enemy that
maybe doesn't see it coming and you know
that's a that's a pattern of history and
if we don't want to see that if we don't
want to see war-like
nations and if we don't want to see
violence within our own culture
monogamy is clearly the way to go it
also has other really important benefits
it increases the tendency towards
cooperation in other words full siblings
have twice the reason to cooperate as
half siblings do
it causes
males to all be brought into productive
activities and frankly the system of
the coherent system of motivation that
arises out of a a circumstance where
all men have the prospect of finding a
mate but need to be worthy in order to
impress someone to to get them to to
accept um them as a mate that that
system actually results in a tremendous
amount of innovation and productivity
in our in our society so yeah the
benefits are many and unfortunately the
sophistications of the moment are
um
self-obsessed
and
they are frankly delusional right we be
you know we hear stories about polyamory
being a better system for
child rearing because basically nobody
knows whose child is is whose and so
everybody participates in raising them
and it'll all be glorious and that's
nonsense men are wired uh to need a high
certainty of paternity before they're
likely to invest well but i think i i
think it's true to give them their due
that in a in a situation in which
no man knows whose child he has fathered
that all men will contribute to
parenting equally which is to say none
at all
that is what that is what will happen i
should say again i hear our detractors
opening yet more champagne because they
will have heard us say something
that argues that adoption doesn't exist
and adoption definitely does exist but
the point is there's a difference
between the eyes wide open version uh
that actually functions for good reasons
there are reasons that people want to
adopt and they're honorable reasons
and the idea that people who just don't
know whose children are whose are going
to invest in them all at some high level
which is not going to happen
heather could i take you back to when
you were talking of
men and and women and equal but not the
same
is that really the core of of the of the
problem here because i know from my own
experience with my wife how empowering
and liberating it is for us both to be
able to say you know with my wife says
why can't you be more like this
for me to be able to say it's because
i'm a man or vice versa for her to be
able to say well i'm behaving in this
way because i'm a woman it's the most
freeing thing for us as a couple but to
say that out loud in public is sexist is
misogynistic to say well but she's like
that because she's a woman or he's like
that because he's a guy
we we're not allowed to do that anymore
it feels like sometimes
that's interesting you know i um
i don't think i've ever said that i
don't think we've ever had those kinds
of you should try i promise you it's
great
well but i think i think we don't
because um it seems i know what you mean
and there's absolute truth in what
you're saying but there's also uh the
risk of a conflation between the
individual and the population right so
to recognize that men and women are
different on you know across many
domains it's not just height and muscle
mass and hip width it's also
variants in many things and interests um
and the interest the difference in
interests like for you know things
versus people um hold for neonates for
babies and across cultures you know this
is not some this is not the western
patriarchy informing us of how we should
behave it's not what it is um but
we are we are we have overlapping
distributions and so you know if i had a
chalkboard here i draw two two bell
curves that are largely overlapping
and um you know that's not that's not
exactly the right description for
something like for instance uh
intelligence like intelligence it seems
that men and women have the same average
intelligence but men have much wider
variance much greater variance and so
there's more male geniuses and more male
idiots than there are women and um on
average
um you know we have about you know the
same intelligence so that's that's
interesting in and of itself um that
said there are female geniuses and
perhaps the smartest woman however you
might want to measure it on earth today
the smartest person on earth today might
be female there is nothing in
the truth of greater variance in male
intelligence than in female intelligence
um suggesting that there couldn't be
women who were smarter than than the
smartest men right so um the population
level truth is absolutely true and we
are ignoring it at our peril it's
ridiculous it's reality denying it's
getting in the way of a tremendous
amount of not just progress at the
societal level but progress for
individuals
uh who are pretending that um that these
differences don't exist but that doesn't
mean that any individual
cannot achieve something because the
because of the sex they were born to
with a few exceptions of course things
like gestation and lactation are simply
you know are simply problematic
[Laughter]
well i i actually would love to have
a conversation where i could say you
know
i'm this way because i'm a man but she
won't put up with it
that's because she's a woman
that's right exactly
um but
the book was fascinating right the way
through i just want to touch on
pornography very very quickly because
it seems to me that and this is coming
from a former teacher that this is a
ticking time bomb and what people don't
seem to understand is
especially online pornography has found
a way to hack our lizard brains and
essentially just get addicted to
dopamine hit after dopamine hit after
dopamine here
it's terrifying isn't it or am i
exaggerating
no you're not exaggerating i i i think
ticking time bomb is a weird analogy
because it seems to have already gone
off yeah i mean it's it's distorting the
way people are interacting and it is
making them
uh much much worse um but the number of
things that are wrong with it and the
reasons are are pretty obvious right so
for one thing
if we define pornography as erotic
content that's generated for profit
which i really think is the best way to
define it and the point is well we know
what an entity trying to make profit off
of sex is you know we know what puzzle
they're trying to solve which is they
need to gain attention in uh you know
and they need to displace competitors
who are trying to gain attention with
the very same
ancient good right there they need to
gain attention by uh with images of
people having sex so how do you
distinguish yourself or you're going to
move in the direction of the extreme in
the direction of taboo in the direction
of things that aren't good like sexual
violence
and the problem is that human beings are
not we don't arrive in the world knowing
how sex works right it's something we
have to learn it's something in fact
you're supposed to learn with a partner
which is an amazing uh
activity to to be engaged in but
the first kind of information that
humans tend to have and at least in an
ancestral environment is you know people
sleeping in the same hut uh the parents
may have sex the children may be
pretending to be asleep they get some
sense of what sex actually looks like
right well if that part of your mind
that's looking to figure out what sex is
is seeing pornography in which people
are choking each other or whatever else
right it begins to think that that is
normal and so now we have this situation
where somehow men and women are supposed
to work side by side treat each other as
equals and then go into the bedroom and
choke each other that that's not going
to work so then we get into this
situation where
you know consent is something that has
to be
sought every two minutes or i don't know
what people are doing right
no
that it you know that that seeking of
consent thing it's actually pretty
unsexy right
the moaning is supposed to be the
indicator of consent right at some level
there's an ancient system there that
we've displaced in favor of some modern
thing that's so market driven that it
can't help but distort our view
well and in this as in so many things
and many of the systems we talk about in
the book part of the problem is that
we've cleaned up the childhood
environment so much
that the first exposure that children
will have to sex is my god from porn
right from complete strangers doing
things for a market
as opposed to um
you know maybe you know maybe stumbling
across adults or
playing you know playing doctor or
whatever the hunter-gatherer version of
that was you know exploring
sexually as as children
in
in interesting reasonable ways and
um and thus coming of age already with
some sense of what bodies are what their
bodies can do what feels good what
doesn't as opposed to
nope childhood is a time for um for none
of that that's that's that's not what's
supposed to happen during childhood at
all and therefore we're going to let the
screens do it for you like that's an
insane way to teach children about sex
and that's exactly what we're doing so
yeah ticking time bomb absolutely how do
you know how can we
allow children to
to actually be children and to do to to
play in school yards and skin their
knees and to look at each other across a
classroom and make eye contact and do a
little flirting at you know at younger
ages than we are currently imagining is
possible
and say okay as long as no one is crying
foul as long as no one is actually
getting hurt in in a real way this is
actually how we learn to be adults um
and instead we cocoon them you know we
we put the children in little boxes and
we keep them from all risk and we drug
them and we give them screens and you
know we do the other things as well but
the the helicopter parenting and the
schools that do the same thing
that keep you know that keep referees in
all sports and free play isn't possible
means that of course people arrive at
the cusp of adulthood with the bodies of
adults with the brains of children
and just uh coming back to porn for a
second and i i let's keep the kids being
exposed to aside although we don't seem
to be able to do that in our society but
for the sake of this argument let's try
and separate the two isn't there some
evidence that societies which do have
pornography a have less sexual violence
and also that you might also describe
the existence of pornography as adaptive
i mean i remember visiting greece and
they have these like 5 000 year old
little clay models of pornography on
them and stuff like that so um no you're
shaking your head brett yeah i always
seem to maybe they were painted in 1974
but you know what i mean no i i know
what you mean i just disagree with your
terminology that was not porn okay that
was erotica and we draw this distinction
quite clearly there's nothing wrong with
erotica right it's not all good but the
point is if somebody has something to
say sexually that's completely valid
it's a very ancient process it is the
market that is distorting this it is the
idea that you want to see something
sexual and then somebody wants to meet
that need and they have some competitor
that they have to overwhelm and that is
going to result in
uh you know incest being the subject
right incest is bad for a biological
reason we now well understand but didn't
right we knew it was bad but we didn't
understand the problem of deleterious
recessive genes coming together when
when siblings mate for example so it was
taboo
because selection caused us to view it
that way correctly and now it is being
explored in porn because it's a way to
differentiate some porn from others so
there's nothing wrong with the erotica
it is ancient yes you'll find sexuality
represented in virtually every culture
but
um it is the immediate gratification
that comes from the market's desire to
get you to spend money you would not
spend that is so destructive it is also
incredibly destructive to have it so
easily available that it replaces your
mind's sexual creativity right you
become a consumer of sexual narrative
rather than a generator and this is kind
of you know uncomfortable stuff to talk
about but there's a reason that human
minds are obsessed with sex in the way
they are and men are different in this
regard they are differently obsessed but
they are obsessed with sexual content
and
the
point is you are supposed to obsess over
details you are supposed to obsess over
real people it actually affects how you
move through the world what you want and
what you'll do when you get in range
right you're supposed to be generating
scenarios that have relevance to the
real world not fantasizing about the
hunky pizza guy right
right so the point is we are denying
kids that landscape and we are turning
them into sexual consumers rather than
people who will participate in some
relationship that will be
likely the most important one in their
lives with some toolkit that's ready to
handle it
um
the uh bri and heather that it's full of
i know we've we've had what seems like a
fairly negative conversation but
actually the book is full of
recommendations and
ways that advise you in terms of food
which is something and sleep which is
things we haven't really talked about
maybe this is a good chunk as we get
towards the end of the interview part uh
to talk about that
talk to us about some of the new
adaptations that we can make at the
individual level and also the societal
level to start to address some of the
problems that we've created for
ourselves
well i mean you know to
pick up on the conversation we've been
having we have some new tools at our
disposal birth control for example
allows women to choose if and when to
reproduce and how much that means that
we have a whole new set of opportunities
with respect to
careers that women can enter and
participate in in different ways so we
have all of these opportunities that are
the result of a technology but that
technology has downsides as well it is
causing people to treat sex uh in a
frivolous way that is causing them to be
less kind to each other to prioritize
the building of meaningful permanent
relationships at a much lower level and
so the the question as with all of these
things is how do we take the advantages
that come from novel technology and
separate them from the costs that happen
when we deploy those technologies
arbitrarily
so um that was that was not a suggestion
that was staying negative i've got a
positive
um
that sort of um that comes to that
brings together some of the things
you've talked about the you know sex
relationship and sleep which is to say
um
anyone who's had a newborn in the weird
world has thought in advance at any rate
about how it is that they're not going
to be sleep deprived for the first many
months of their life with that newborn
and one of you know birth control is an
incredible modern invention that has
freed women and the opportunities
available to us and therefore couples as
well greatly and of course that it comes
with costs too
similarly
the ability to express breast milk and
to save it for later so that the mother
does not have to be on hand at all
moments that her baby might need that
breast milk
is a wonderful modern invention but as
actually one of our students back at
evergreen uh began to wonder with regard
to why you know why are there so many
sleep problems in in newborns in the
weird world she began to wonder if given
that we now know that breast milk is not
just nutrition just like food is not
just nutrition um and not just even
immune information
but possibly other things as well maybe
it is helping to entrain the sleep cycle
maybe it is helping to establish a
circadian rhythm for the baby
and therefore uh it is hypothesized and
we and we do have this in the book uh
that if you are in the position where
you are a new mother and you have a
partner who is is you know willing and
able to help feed your child and your
child is only getting breast milk uh
that when you express milk
putting not just the date but the time
on it so that if the baby gets up at two
in the middle of the night and it's
dad's time to feed the baby
if you pull a bottle from the freezer
that is from two in the afternoon there
is a good chance that you have just sent
that child the signal it is daytime it
is time to wake up and play now and that
baby may now be well fed and well awake
and not ready to go back to sleep you
know it is time to rock and roll and
what you want to send the signal is you
are now well fed it is still the middle
of the night we are all sleeping and so
should you be
and um the simple you know the simple
fix to the modern wonder that is the
ability to control our reproduction and
our feeding of our babies of
of time stamping
breast milk that you've expressed um may
well help with the sleep deprivation
that so many new parents experience so
that's just you know that's that's kind
of involved but there are a lot of
things like this where okay it's not the
modernity is bad modernity is fast it's
too fast changing for us to keep up very
well but if we think evolutionarily
there is often something that we can
just add to what it is that we're doing
in order to get some of the coherence
back
and what about some of the stuff that if
you hadn't just written this book
we'd normally be talking with you guys
about on the show
which is uh i mean i can i'm trying to
make it less negative than it's going to
come out but you know
i'm tempted to describe it as the slow
or rapid breakdown of society depending
on how you see it but you know what i
mean right
and you're kind of uh alluding to with
the impact of the sexual revolution the
impact of the hookup culture and all of
that that has downstream consequences
which we see on the streets which we see
you see in in your former college etc
etc etc
how are we going to fix that
well
uh okay how can i say
i don't know
but if we were gonna fix it
the first step would be recognizing what
the process is that is creating all of
the dysfunction and recognizing that as
incoherent as a lot of the complaints
about western civilization have become
that the frustration is actually about
something right we have an incredibly
productive society that does not
distribute things well it does not
protect people from for example the
consequences of bad luck which we
absolutely should do right protecting
people from the consequences of bad
decisions is a mistake but protecting
them from the consequences of bad luck
is our obligation and it's good for all
of us to do it
so the first step is recognizing what
we're doing wrong one thing we're doing
wrong is we are letting markets decide
what we should want rather than just
simply deciding how best to solve
problems that we have uh handed to them
and then the second thing is to
recognize
that on our current trajectory we know
that the resources of planet earth will
not continue to support us that we are
actually headed into great danger that
that is not a situation that is totally
novel many past populations have faced
situations like that but that in order
to get out of a trajectory that is
likely to be fatal or at least extremely
destructive the right thing to do
is for us to rise to what we call
collective consciousness and get serious
about the question of how else we might
exist so that we don't have this and you
know what we have is a civilization that
has been a fantastic prototype but the
structures you know 18th century
solutions to how we will govern
ourselves just simply aren't adequate to
our modern problems it's time to figure
out how to take the things that they
discovered that do work and the values
that they correctly focused on and build
them into a system that is capable of
mod of dealing with modern problems so
anyway that's the last chapter of the
book is about that
and you touch upon that this idea and
that in our society we're addicted to
growth
and we believe that growth is always
good but in the sense growth is just
slowly destroying us well and really
life is addicted to growth all evolved
beings are addicted to growth so that
again it's not it's not just about the
weird societies it is it is what we are
so you know we argue in the book without
without pretending to provide a
blueprint because
um we argue that we we need to get to
the beginning of an adaptive foothill so
that we can climb from there and explore
what the future can look like that is
maximally productive and fair for all
but um the growth itself
is yes an addiction but we do crave it
so how can we create the sensation of
growth without actually using more stuff
so we need to grow
with things that are non-zero sum things
like creativity and innovation
and you know lasting contributions
rather than the throwaway junk culture
that we have now which is accelerating
the rate at which growth is killing us
and this may sound like a nonsense
fantasy but it's really we're invoking
something that's actually got um plenty
of precedent right spring is delightful
right the idea that you should always
want it to be spring may seem fanciful
but we make it spring all the time in
our homes and we don't violate any rules
of physics to do it the fact is you've
got a steady state and uh you know as
you're cooling your house you're warming
the backyard and that's just simply how
it works so the question is how can we
do that same trick with um
our human senses so that our growth is
not eroding the world out from under us
and so that each generation leaves a
world as intact as the one it inherited
that ought to be our goal it's really
our obligation and it is possible but
it's not going to happen automatically
the market's not going to find this the
market has in fact caused the problem
because we've given it hegemony over not
just how to solve problems but what
problems to address
you were almost positive there for a sec
but you went back to there is no
solution
you didn't quite say that you know the
key the key to a meaningful positivity
is staring into the abyss until it stops
freaking you out
well on that sounds scary yeah
on that very positive note uh we are
going to take a short break for
questions reminder guys if you want to
send in a question for brett and heather
do so using the super chat anton has
been collating them or the paypal link
is in the description we're going to
take about a three-minute break we'll
come back uh with questions directly
from you for the guys and we very much
look forward to that we'll see you in
three minutes
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
hey kk do you like music yes but only if
it's on bala like and we have returned
from successful day bear hunting okay
music must only be played in group when
we drink the blood of our enemies well
if you're interested in rock music then
elite by tria is a band for you they're
an alternative rock band that stand up
against cancel culture and the creeping
authoritarianism in society they're like
a combination of nine inch nails
radiohead and allison chains this sounds
good we must have them headline bear
fest in russia support truly independent
music by joining their free fan
community sign up at go dot
elitefytria.com
and get a free merch bundle that
includes an autographed photo fridge
magnet stickers guitar picks and secret
bonus gift
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
all right welcome back everybody let's
get bret and heather back as well anton
and let's get to the question we've got
a bunch of questions uh guys the first
is actually two questions from two
separate people but very much the same
subject i'm gonna merge them into one uh
don john says jonathan height who you
both know states that woke universities
are here to stay
the other institutions of learning
should be established to counter them
and fm very much on that subject says
would you consider organizing a new
university one without illiberalism or
what recommendations would you make on
current universities in the us
oh boy yeah
big big necessary question
can the existing institutions be saved
or do we need new systems entirely
maybe
maybe some of them
can be saved kind of but we definitely
need a new system because we need a
functioning system of higher ed
um we did spend a little bit over a year
working on a project to try to bootstrap
a new kind of higher ed based on some of
what we learned at evergreen because
despite what you know despite what
everyone knows about however however
green blew up and you know how we came
to the public eye at all it really did
have some extraordinary foundational
principles uh which allowed for
education in a way that um
that doesn't happen elsewhere you know
the full-time interaction with students
really getting to know people well the
problem is that's hard to make scale
right and so you know what you're doing
and what we're doing uh with with
podcast trigonometry
is a kind of education but it doesn't
for the most part allow for a back and
forth so you can't get to know the
people and that is um you know that is
definitely a restriction on how how far
you can go with it so
um
yes um
brett and i both individually and
together have considered and are
considering ways in which we might
uh
think about new models of higher ed
but
it is
there are many challenges i'll leave it
in there
all right a couple of things i don't
think these institutions can be saved
i think it's more or less the point
where your dog has rabies and the idea
is that's not really your dog anymore
right that's a that's an animal with
rabies and it's got to go
i do think alternative institutions are
the way to go there's a reason that it
will be difficult to create them the
first question that you have to ask
yourself at the point you decide to set
up such a thing
is will you seek accreditation if so you
have one failure mode you will turn into
exactly the same thing that you're
trying to replace or will you not seek
accreditation in which case you will be
hobbled by all of the obstacles that
will have been placed in your path in
order to keep the stranglehold on
education that the current accredited
system has so
at some point people are going to
realize actually i don't want the
students from the accredited institution
because they're all crazy
right i want the students from the
institution that makes sense that isn't
accredited and isn't crazy because it's
not accredited or that allowed for it
not to be crazy
and because of that there will be a
massive attempt to stamp out any new
types of and stamp out or capture any
new institutions that aren't accredited
and show signs of being able to do this
so that's really where the battle is
going to be and as soon as you've got
one established others will grow so the
battle will be over the first one right
will somebody be able to stabilize an
alternative university let's say
um that effectively educates while not
participating in this woke
nonsense and if they can get one then
that'll be a model and we'll get a new
system and you know the fact is the
other system will collapse because who's
going to hire the graduates yeah so let
me just
one one thing in the us i don't know the
system in the uk
but in the u.s being accredited gives
you access to federal grants and the
federal grants come in two large
categories many more than this but the
two the two that are the most concerning
are
the
grants for low-income students so
without things like pell grants in the
united states most students could not go
to college and if you're not accredited
you can't get pell grants therefore you
can't attract low-income students
and the other big category is
grants for research and because again of
the problem of the market forces driving
so much of what has happened in higher
ed for the last many decades
most science now is big science which is
to say expensive science and the value
of big science to institutions is
hopefully sometimes yes the science
itself but unfortunately much of the
value is that institutions get a
tremendous
percentage
of the overhead on those grants and so
if you are not accredited and therefore
your big science science faculty cannot
apply for funds from in the us it would
be nsf and ihdod
even if they can get grants even if
there's somehow you know massive
philanthropy philanthropic money through
which they can get grants to do their
work it will be very hard to to move
back and forth between that system and
one which is accredited because they
will have no history of grant getting
the likes of which all of their peers do
so what we don't want is two still
functioning systems that work side by
side but can't interact with one another
of higher ed we need a way for you know
for for all communication to happen for
science to work across boundaries for
education to work across boundaries and
um it it can't work if there is this
still struggling with its last breaths
accredited system which is holding on to
all of the federal money and uh an
unaccredited system which may may have
philanthropic money but will not allow
either students is bread alluded to or
faculty to move back and forth between
the two
and also a more societal level worry
that that i think ought to be included
in this conversation and tell me what
you think about this we just interviewed
vivek ramaswamy who's written a book
called woke inc and one of the things he
was talking about was that if you go
down the path of creating two markets
essentially you have you know
woke people shopping buying their coffee
only from starbucks and everyone else
buying their coffee from black rifle uh
eventually you get to a point where you
are actually gonna get to civil war
because the interests are just so
diametrically opposed there's nothing
holding you together and is it not
then i mean is it not that desirable to
at least to try and reform these
institutions or maybe to just wait until
the next generation who are desperate to
push back against their millennial
parents get in there or or do you not
see that happening brett well i don't
think civil war is all that likely in
the next
few weeks i would say
sorry again
he's not in a good mood what you've been
feeding him
what are you talking about no
look here's the problem okay
i don't disagree that if you have two
separate systems that they point us in
this direction on the other hand we have
been watching and trying to call
attention to the growing dysfunction in
the academy
for decades
right it does not listen it will not
rescue itself there is no level of
obviousness that is sufficient to get it
to wake up and so
again here's the problem
maybe you've got a dog sled team
and your dogs have rabies
right now the argument might be well we
can't very well shoot the dogs because
they're our dog sled team right we'll be
stuck here
but you have to shoot the dogs because
they have rabies that's where we are and
my point is that's not the fault of
those of us who have tried to explain
that this was happening that it was a
lethal danger i mean we started making
this point in the 90s
right
they won't listen and because they won't
listen they've got a system that can't
be rescued so yes we have to rescue it
and it's not going to work it's time
that we stop kidding ourselves about
that
and you know it's possible if you
generate the parallel system
and it demonstrates value that some of
those institutions will say hey we're
going to get left in the dust let's
abandon this trajectory and let's reboot
the university great let's bring them
along right after all they have
beautiful campuses they've got libraries
all
stocked with books they've got
everything you need
in order to run a university except for
a staff that knows what they're doing
right or maybe the staff does but the
faculty largely doesn't right so that's
the problem and we could reinfuse them
with with competent people but
you know i'm not arguing that the
situation is um
uh healthy if we have to start from
scratch it's a terrible waste but you
know having watched how we got there i
don't think there's a lot of hope for
them waking up and i guess there's
there's another dimension along which
we're dividing which maybe it won't be
surprising given that what we're talking
about is sort of woke versus not woke
but
um in the u.s anyway the sex ratio of
college students is becoming ever more
skewed it's like 60 40 now women to men
and the prediction is that within not
not too much time it's going to be two
to one
and this this means that there are a
whole lot of young men who are doing
something that's not college who would
otherwise have been going to college
therefore we're already getting this
this system you know there it's not that
there aren't always going to be many
people who don't go to college and
that's fine and many people are
incredibly productive and and do
wonderful things without that but for
those people who intended to go to
college who wanted to go to college who
thought that they would benefit from it
if men more than women are saying not
for me not that kind not with education
looking that way uh then we are we are
exactly moving towards chaos because um
that can't that won't last
and this question is actually loosely
tied into what we're talking about and
it's from mackie mckinney
can you explain what critical race
theory is and what is so dangerous about
it my girlfriend is getting her phd and
claims it's all overblown nonsense and i
don't understand what it is exactly
love you both
nice finish there yeah it was full shop
then love you both um
yeah i mean
we could you know james lindsay would do
a a better job as with helen pluck rose
or peter pagozian but you know critical
race theory began with a
honorable study into structural biases
in the court system of which there are
structural biases that resulted in a
person having different prospects given
a case with the same uh the same
evidence based on the color of their
skin so this is decades ago it's like
late 70s or so decades ago but it
evolved into an obsession with race that
effectively assumes that any difference
in outcome is inherently the result of
oppression and this becomes perfectly
absurd in fact some of the jokes that we
once made about conclusions that would
ultimately be reached have now been
reached and broadcast so for example
um you know the the idea that there is
something about uh the modern um
system of national parks
that must be racist because the races
are not equally represented there
well that's not true you can go to a
national park and you can demonstrate
the fee is the same nobody looks twice
at you no matter what you look like if
you pay the fee you're able to go in
this has something to do with
preferences and now those preferences
may ultimately be traceable to
disparities in other words populations
that haven't had access to the national
parks
in the past
for various reasons may be less likely
to find value in those things now just
because the tradition of going there
hasn't been passed down but that's not
the same thing as saying the system is
currently white supremacist and that is
the reason that we find different color
people here than there right bike lanes
aren't white supremacist national parks
aren't white supremacist
colleges aren't white supremacists and
the assumption that they must be or
everything would be dead even is um
absolutely illogical and it is and the
fact that this has now spilled out of
colleges into all of these structures
that it's in fact moving through
corporations of all places
and taking over uh their approach to
managing relations
within their staff
is evidence that somehow the conclusion
is sacred and it is immune to reason
yeah so it's
viewing the world through entirely
through a racial lens without any
ability to consider other factors
which you know there will be those who
say okay intersectionality is trying to
encourage all you know us to think about
all these factors but of course it's
just the demographics that are
fashionable of the moment that we're
supposed to be talking about so as brett
alluded to cynical theories by uh helen
plecos and james lindsey does a terrific
job of describing what this is and where
it's gotten to
um but the the fact is it's being used
as an ideology which is to say something
that you must accept and shall not
question
in institutions of higher learning and
in k-12 schools in in the earlier
schooling as well and
it's indoctrinating rather than
educating you are told to accept this
and accept that your skin color is both
your fate
and um describes whether you are
oppressed or oppressor and that feels
like the very opposite of what anything
claiming to be liberal arts education
should be teaching actually i want to
amend my answer for succinctness
it is the inverse of the colorblind
society
right and colorblind society has been
falsely portrayed as a myth because
people aren't colorblind but colorblind
society means that the court needs to be
colorblind to you when you come in it
needs to treat you with indifference to
your race which is true as we do need to
as employers or educators or anything
else and so
critical race theory is the idea that we
have to be racially obsessed rather than
work towards being indifferent to race
in the distribution of well-being
without pretending that it doesn't exist
right
oh well as you say uh peter bogotti and
james lindsey helen plug cross and
christopher roofer who we had on the
show recently all do a pretty good job
explaining this and we've had them all
on the show uh we've got a question from
someone who wants to be kept anonymous
which i don't know why because their
question really isn't particularly
incendiary they're they're asking why
people believe in utopias
um
um why people believe in utopia i think
actually there's a there's a pretty good
evolutionary explanation for this
and that is
if you think about what creatures uh
ought to be wired to do they ought to be
wired to solve problems that are
accessible to them in other words if a
creature is
moving through its landscape
inefficiently in the pursuit of food
then moving through it more efficiently
is the equivalent of finding more food
right because it wastes less
so we have an obsession with problem
solving that doesn't have anything to do
with us being humans but we humans do it
in a human way now the problem is if
you're obsessed with problem solving
right and it troubles you as it troubles
me that my refrigerator puts heat into
my kitchen in the summer right i want my
refrigerator actually outside of the
wall of my kitchen so that it puts heat
into my backyard and doesn't heat my
house when i don't want my house heated
right that's a solvable problem
so if you get into that mindset where
you spot all the little things that are
wrong and you try to think about how we
would do them in a way that's better
then you will at some point arrive at
the idea that this could all be
perfected but you won't at first
understand what perfected would have to
mean right you won't understand what
trade-offs are and you will imagine that
you could solve every problem
simultaneously and wouldn't that be
marvelous you can't because those
problems are in tension with each other
right there's a reason that the
refrigerator isn't on the outside wall
and it has to do with the efficiency of
building homes and you have to decide
which is the priority or at what level
you will balance them
so basically the idea is a naive problem
solver that looks into society and sees
all of the problems but doesn't
understand what the downsides of the
solutions would be or how they would
interact
arrives at the idea aha i know what we
should do and they end up trying to
maximize something that is their
focal obsession and everything else
crashes as they try to maximize it so
effectively it is the intermediate level
of understanding yes there are lots of
problems to be solved but you need to be
sophisticated about how you do it rather
than naive so the person asking the
question doesn't seem to think that
utopia is a desirable endpoint or or a
possible one but one of the other errors
in those who who do
um who do strive for utopia is
imagining that we live in a static world
right like not only do trade-offs
preclude utopia as brett just suggested
but you know in evolution everything is
context dependent and the reason that
there is no fittest state to be in
uh with any permanence is because
environments change so uh what what it
is that you want um today is not
necessarily going to be the thing that
you want in a week
and it also the concept of utopia also
forgets or never understands that
actually the striving itself is part of
where we derive our pleasure from
so just you know actually to go back to
one of the things we were talking about
in the first hour um one of the reasons
that people aren't sexually satisfied
now even though sex is available all the
time at every moment is that the chase
is gone right that there is that there
isn't that that period of oh i wonder if
i i could i might i'm not sure oh that's
felt like a setback but maybe i'm now
moving closer that that is that is
actually part of the fun that is part of
what feels like um
productivity and joy and allows you to
be driven to be creative or analytical
or whatever it is that is your pr
your particular toolkit with which to
make progress in the world
and so you know getting getting to the
state wherein everything is fine well
it's guaranteed not to feel fine for
more than a little while because you
your brain will then continue to seek
growth
let me follow up on that hillary because
as you were talking it was actually
quite interesting because i was thinking
how what you're saying about evolution
and i've heard this phrase obviously a
billion times it's the species most
adaptable to change that blah blah blah
but i was thinking about it on an
individual level in our society we tend
to teach people uh you know you go to
school you get your grades then you go
to college you get your degree then you
get a phd then you and you train
increasingly specialized to do one thing
and you get more specialized and more
and by the time you're 50 hopefully
you're like the one person in the world
that can do that thing right the problem
is in our society by the time you're 50
that thing might not need to be done
anymore so on a personal level what
advice i think young people watching
this are people who are kind of in limbo
perhaps
what ought to be a useful attitude at
the individual level to how you develop
as a human being so that you as an
individual are adaptable to change
the ant one of the answers is exactly in
your question right you know explore
lots and lots of domains anything that
you think you might be interested in
explore that and don't ever assume that
you're too old but also recognize that
there are developmental periods during
which it will be easier to learn another
language pick up a musical instrument
that sort of thing right
and specifically explore like generate
skills generate expertise or even just
some facility you know you need not be
expert in lots and lots of things but
the more things in which you have some
facility the more broad thinking you're
likely to be and the better a problem
solver you are likely to be and make
sure that some of those things
live in the physical world
such that the outcome that you create
cannot be negotiated away such that you
know you either did or did not build a
table that holds the weight of the
plates on it you did or did not bake a
cake that other people say yeah this
tastes good um and it and it doesn't
poison them right um things things need
to
you will be best taught
to
recognize the actual feedback that the
world can give you by making things in
it wherein the world is giving you the
feedback as opposed to the people in it
and you can always coerce the people so
i think the line in the book is
something like
you can um
oh boy you can't trick a tractor or a
tree you know you can but you can fool
another person it's i didn't get the
line right but it's it's something to
that effect you can fool another person
but you can't fool reality yeah i would
say two things one invest in tools right
knowledge is free and the domain may
change but if you've invested in tools
that can be adapted to whatever new
domain emerges you'll be better off and
if you've engaged with physical systems
then you will have a good intuitive idea
of how things actually work whereas if
you've invested in abstractions
that the person at the front of the room
told you you were being smart about the
person at the front of the room may be a
fool and so they may have miseducated
you
but an engine won't do that right
gardening won't do that the stuff either
grows or it doesn't so
those two things
we have a question now from a very
passionate supporter of ours called eli
munoz and he said i've heard physicists
talk about sensing the divine in deep
math
have you discovered anything like that
in deep bio biology or in jungle forest
studies
yeah i mean i think we all
have our version of this
um
i call mine the cosmic joke
right the cosmic joke can be told a
thousand ways and every so often you
watch a creature do something and
suddenly you understand what must be
going on inside of that creature's mind
for example right and suddenly you
realize well
isn't it fascinating that the universe
generated a creature that could solve a
problem like that and that that would be
true whether there was anybody here to
notice at all if humans had never
evolved that squirrel would still be
doing that thing right with no one there
to appreciate it right so yeah there's
there's the
um the marvel
of biology that exists i was thinking
the other day about
even a house fly right we look at a
house fly and mostly we feel disgust
because a house fly may have walked on
feces before it walks on your lunch
right so they are grotesque in one way
but if you think about
the mechanism of a housefly
and even the structure it's a beautiful
creature it really you know gorgeous
eyes that are almost like multifaceted
jewels this incredibly sophisticated
flight architecture it's an amazing
creature and these things fly by us and
we don't give it a second thought so
yeah there is something about just
looking at what selection has produced
and thinking
what a gift it is to be the kind of
creature who can even understand what
that object is how it must work in some
regard um and you know appreciate the
process
that that created it i get i think what
you're describing um
i would call aw
right
very often being in in the amazon in
nature in portland everywhere in between
i am filled with awe
uh for me i
i don't use the language of of the
divine
and i remember actually being um
being in high school and searching for
meaning as i think all human beings do
unless they are they have it
drugged and bad parented and bad
education out of them or something
but we all do a lot of active searching
for meaning
and purpose um especially during those
teenage years and um i was dabbling here
and there i was thinking about buddhism
i was thinking about various ways of
approaching what what is the meaning of
all of this
and um and actually
it was it was you a couple years into
college brett and i had been friends
throughout
high school and about halfway through
college we we got together
and you gave me
a richard dawkins book gave him the
blind watchmaker and said that i
might find some things in there that i
would find interesting and
uh for me that was that was the moment
it just it opened up and i thought
this is going to turn out this way of
understanding the world an evolutionary
understanding of the world and this
doesn't contain everything but this has
the seeds in it
will turn out to hold so much
of the meaning i've been looking for and
also it will enable me to still have a
sense of awe and mystery about the
universe
when we used to when we used to teach um
heather and i talked privately about
what was
minimally necessary to convey in a
program you know for it to be worth the
students while we used to talk about the
keys to the kingdom and the idea was
they need to walk away from the program
with enough that if they got the message
and it means something to them that they
can then go forward without us being
there to direct them right they need
enough of the tools to say aha here's
what these questions are here's how i
might go about answering them here are
the kinds of people who have insight
that actually contributes to my ability
to do that and you know
for many of them it worked many of them
demanded that we
write some kind of book that would allow
them to pass the thing on to their
friends and this book is in large
measure the result of that process
do you ever stop and think but you know
like you described the house fly
you'd see certain animals you get
confronted by or inspiring visas that
there must be a god that this simply
can't have been created
you know organically that there must be
some kind of divine creator did you just
ask two evolutionary biologists in
seeing evolution in action they make
they think of god yeah is that what
happened i dig it i like the
questionnaire
there are evolutionary biologists who
would say yes
and i will tell you that i check in with
that explanation frequently and i ask
myself have i yet seen something that
cannot in principle be explained by the
process that we are studying
and i will tell you the result of
checking in with that idea very
frequently is that i know for sure there
is a missing level
that the process in the evolution
textbook does not explain the creatures
that we see and that's not because there
is a divine uh influence it's because we
have fooled ourselves into imagining
that random mutations being selected is
sufficient to change
something that's like a shrew into
something that's like a bat and it's not
there's an amplifier in there that we
have not described well and i think if
you watch
i'll assuming civilization hangs
together
we're going to discover that layer and
that layer is going to make it a lot
easier to understand how the creatures
emerged uh in the marvelous form that we
find them
well that is spicy indeed
it is good all right well that then you
understood it because that's the point
is yeah you've been given a a
description of a process that's too
crude to have done the things that you
see and that's not your mind playing
tricks on you um
but there's no reason to think
uh we can't rule out a divine influence
but there's it's not i don't think it's
going to be necessary because there are
darwinian processes that will fill in
that gap some of which we um begin to
outline in the book yep actually
that's great uh well it's a question
about human beings now uh winter mu
says i think this from switzerland says
i always assumed history repeats itself
uh because human nature doesn't change
we fall into the same traps over and
over again because our brains haven't
evolved much for about 200 000 years is
there a remedy stroke am i wrong he or
she says
right and wrong
um
there is a tendency for problems to be
very similar and therefore us to fall
into the same traps there's a very sad
pattern
where we solve a problem and then
having solved that problem people forget
that it was a problem and they dismantle
the solution and reinvent it
that's awfully frustrating whatever
could you be talking about
so many things um yeah i mean
dismantling the west because it isn't
working fairly is absurd right let's fix
the unfairness about it let's diagnose
it correctly and fix it but um
so there is that but then there is also
the possibility of
you know i think people don't know
enough about game theory
um
and the reason that i
hit this drum frequently is that game
theory nicely takes all of these very
specific problems and gives us a general
name for a failure right so a tragedy of
the commons
or a collective action problem
the point is
you can have a hundred versions of that
but they're variations on a theme and
the solutions will look alike as eleanor
ostrom's nobel prize winning work tells
us that ancient cultures figured out
solutions to these things and in fact
their solutions were presented in uh in
uh narrative
metaphorical form because they had to be
right they didn't know the game theory
so anyway that's a hopeful sign because
what it means is if we can study these
things correctly we can actually
generate solutions that we can apply
each time the problem re-emerges and we
should be shooting for that
fantastic the next question is from
casey khan
and uh this person asks can you talk
about the evolutionary utility of
whistleblowers
are there any examples of
proto-whistleblower protections
asking for a friend
so was that proto whistleblower
protections is that what the second yeah
yes are there any examples
i think the problem is almost turned on
its head
because the point is in an ancestral
circumstance if we go sufficiently far
back
the lineage right the tribe or the band
would be united in wanting to spot the
problems because they were bad for the
long-term prospects of the people
involved and so what has happened is by
generating these very large systems
in which uh one group effectively does
oppress another whether that's you know
one race oppressing another or
management oppressing workers or
whatever it is
there becomes a need for somebody who
can endure the mechanisms that are built
to frustrate the process of correcting
an injustice right so the need for
whistleblowers is new and so the search
for the ancient solution is probably
wrong-headed but yeah you want to you
want to enhance the quality of the world
figure out how to make people safe for
pointing out the uncomfortable true
things that uh describe what jeopardizes
us yeah i think this is right i think
this is one of the relatively rare
situations where it might almost be a a
step function like there was there was a
scale
of organization below which
whistleblowing wasn't necessary because
it was all done by people who knew one
another and so as we scale up we become
more anonymous and and you know people
effectively become commodities such that
whistleblowing is the necessary
sometimes the only way
to fix the wrongs whereas you could have
done it by more ancient human
interaction before and that's not
there's nothing actionable in that but
i'm afraid that that
fascinating question but i think i think
that's
where i'm going to land well i would
take the example of um what banking
used to be versus what it's become if
you imagine some even just a couple
hundred years ago you know the banker
who was going to actually carry the loan
that they were giving you
needed to really make sure that you were
in a decent position to pay it back
right they had no interest in lying to
themselves about that the subprime
mortgage crisis involved a lot of people
who knew that they were going to make a
loan and then sell it and therefore
wouldn't be there
when things went bad and it created a
whole system of perverse incentives so
what happened
that problem-solving modality
couldn't figure out why we shouldn't you
know allow you to
bundle mortgages and sell them
uh as a package right and you know it's
hard to describe why you shouldn't be
able to
now we've seen what happens if nobody
can figure out how to explain the
problem
but we have to recognize that we're
doing that to ourselves all the time
there are lots of things we shouldn't do
but it's very hard to explain why
and it isn't part of the problem as well
that
when you whistle blow you automatically
expel yourself from the group
and as primarily tribal creatures that
goes against our are very our very
instincts does it not
well but that's the so
not here but elsewhere
i've talked about a process i call
cultivated insecurity where the system
of your life the fact that your mortgage
your insurance
your retirement
all depend on the relationship with an
employer places you in a very awkward
position because you may be doing well
but it can all go south all of a sudden
this is of course somewhat different in
the uk right there are distinctions but
i guess the point is the cultivated
insecurity makes it very hard to do
something like be a whistleblower and
the remedy is
a system that actually not only protects
whistleblowers but if you spot something
that's actually a hazard to lots of
people or threatens to destroy a great
deal of public wealth or whatever
you should be rewarded for calling
attention to it so you want to cultivate
security um you know you're right
britain is going to be better at least
with respect to something like health
care which is not dependent on your
relationship with your employer so
cultivating security so that people are
free to describe what they see and to
call attention to bad patterns is the
key if you want those kinds of problems
solved and the fact that we are so
desperately insecure um and so dependent
on our relationship with uh the people
we would be blowing the whistle on
um is the reason you know
from the point of view of the public
it's a bug but from the point of view of
the people who don't wish to have the
whistle blown it's a feature i guess one
of the things is um
recognizing actually that we all belong
to multiple tribes
and uh imagining that the group that
you're whistleblowing against may feel
like your home group your home team
but as those of us who have experienced
cancer culture can attest um it turns
out that there are many many people out
there who think many things and who are
interested in coming together into what
might be seen as tribal affiliation um
you had no access to before for instance
um or whom by some descriptors might
appear to be of a very different tribe
entirely and so we can you know we can
use demographic characteristics or
political ideology or
um
excuse me or you know teams that we vote
for or places that we live
as the ways that we describe the tribes
to which we belong but really trying to
identify as many as possible of these
things by which we might group ourselves
and then finding others in those groups
such that yes we're tribal of course in
group out group dynamics are real and
they will never go away but the more
groups to whom you feel a sense of
belonging and feel like you're on the in
group there
the less fraught being whistleblowing
being a whistleblower will be and also
the more secure you will actually be and
more capable of actually standing up and
being courageous when it's called for
guys i should say we've got a lot of
messages flowing in which aren't
questions but just people appreciating
you coming on the show and are spending
this time talking together and of course
we appreciate that as well um and we
appreciate your appreciation
the mutual appreciation society is in
session uh but uh speaking of uh
cultivated insecurity i caution you
about this question uh important john we
did say we'd take a a covered question
or two and by the way for everybody
watching we'll do another 10 minutes or
15 minutes if you guys are happy to
stick around so if you want to send in a
super chat or paypal go ahead and do
that
but here's important john
and he says
drumroll please if you had a choice
between taking the vaccine or waiting to
get covered and then taking over mechtin
which would you personally choose and
why
okay this is this is a dangerous
question for us and it's not that
analytically speaking we shouldn't be
able to address it
are you indicating that you can't hear
me no no i can't hear you i've just got
this thing in my ear that's all it's
it's a bit irritating
there are no hidden signals or anything
like that no no no for it
yeah no it's it's because they're
uncomfortable in my ears
all right
so the problem is first of all it must
be said we are not doctors we are not in
a position to advise people about this i
do think people need to be aware that
the information that they have at their
disposal is
quite noisy and compromised by
propaganda of various kinds
we don't know about all of the
consequences of having had covid right
you could say based on what we know now
does it make sense to allow yourself to
get covered and treat it very
aggressively which seems to be possible
we see cases like joe rogan like pierre
cory where very aggressive treatment
seems to turn the disease around right
away and apparently generate natural
immunity which is highly desirable much
better than the immunity generated by
the vaccines here's the problem
we don't know for sure
that covid doesn't do something like
hide in well herpes viruses for example
hide in neurological tissue where
they're shielded from the immune system
and then they re-emerge
we don't have the evidence that covid
does that but could it do that and
therefore if one got the disease
thinking that i'll get it and i'll treat
it would they be
in danger of having a recurring disease
that might you know uh
chickenpox become shingles so diseases
change in their manifestation over time
so we can't rule that out right that's a
very serious problem if it's there
and it changes the answer to the the
question that we've been asked so it's
very hard to make these decisions what
we desperately need
is a group of people who are well
informed on this topic to be completely
insulated from the political and
economic environment that is so
destroyed our ability to talk about it
and we need them to talk about what
actually is the best approach because it
is true we see again and again the
immunity that comes from the disease is
far and away better than the immunity
that comes from the vaccines for two
different reasons one it's broader
because it's to the entire virus not
just one subunit of one protein
and two because it doesn't fade in the
same way that the immunity generated by
the vaccines does
so
it's a complex landscape i don't want to
give an answer because the fact is if we
give an answer it might affect what
people
do and you know we might have an
instinct but the point is what we know
for sure is that we are operating on
incomplete information about the
consequences of
the vaccines and the consequences of
covid
thank you very much brett um so the last
question is uh nowhere near as com as
controversial it's from jaunty speaks
and he asks what's the evolutionary role
of laughter
[Music]
um
it's
yeah you want to start uh it
it
is communicative as so much of what
humans do
and it is it gets back to exactly what
you were just talking about francis with
regard to
establishing tribal boundaries
and
you know there is laughter that feels
wonderful and laughter that can feel
wonderful but even as you're doing it
you know is exclusionary
um
that
both of those functions exist
uh for laughter and
that therefore you know just you know
maybe to go back to the very beginning
of our conversation it's not
laughter is adaptive it's present in all
the cultures of of all human beings and
that doesn't mean it's good you know
laughter almost always feels good to us
but there are examples when it is uh
malicious when it does harm to uh to
those who are being laughed at
and so saying that it is adaptive uh as
a way of effectively increasing social
cohesion um does not mean that that
social cohesion is necessarily a
wonderful thing because some forms of
social cohesion are actually doing great
damage
so i would i would say years ago i was
working on a a project about this
question not on laughter specifically
but on humor
obviously laughter is an indicator of
humor but
roughly speaking not any more breath
with what i have on comedy shows on tv
actually it reminds me there was a
interview with one of the writers for
the i never saw the show with the show
alf alien life form uh who described
that in the writing room
they had a thing that they called
humor-like substance where you know it
was a half-hour show and they needed a
certain number of jokes and sometimes
they didn't have enough jokes and they
would put in something that had the form
of a joke and then the laugh track would
make it sound like a joke but it just
didn't have the content
um so anyway to your point that sounds
like a horseman of the apocalypse right
there it was a horseman of the
apocalypse but we did not recognize it
the point was uh
the argument that i made in my prior
project was that humor was a mechanism
and in fact the exercise of humor is a
mechanism of exploring things that hover
at the edge of what we are conscious of
and so if you have a room full of people
when you tell a joke
they're erupting in laughter is a
recognition that they are all suddenly
aware of the same truth that they had
not formally understood they were all
aware of so a good humorist is searching
that landscape for things everybody
knows but people don't say and if you
say it
we can get into why timing might be
important here but if you say it
correctly the point is there's a sudden
dawning of recognition
and serves to cement the tribal
belonging
it serves to both cement the tribal
belonging and to exclude because if you
think about
the person who doesn't get the joke
right if you're the only person in the
room who doesn't laugh that's a
thoroughly uncomfortable
feeling or if you are going to pretend
to get it and you laugh inappropriately
at the joke you laugh and it's not the
punchline yet or whatever you reveal
yourself to be an outsider and it's so
there's that element of the thing but
anyway i was talking to somebody about
this
and they alerted me to a quote that i
didn't know which was tom stoppard who
says
laughter is the sound of comprehension
which i thought was excellent oh of
course that's stoppard yeah that's great
that's wonderful
well speaking of stopping uh thank you
both for joining us it's been an
absolute pleasure we both and all of us
here trigonometry wish you all the very
best with the book tour uh and promoting
the book it's really a book worth
promoting we speak to a lot of people
it's one of those that i really
thoroughly recommend to people and
it's a rare it's a wrath there it is
yeah it is our this is our only copy
they're sold that we had to beg for for
this copy
that's our own well when if it ever
happens that we can visit you over in
the us or you can visit us over here
we're gonna beg you for another copy and
sign please please please
uh but in the meantime thank you so much
for joining us it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you thank you guys it's
been a pleasure thank you thank you very
much
okay guys uh thank you for tuning in uh
as you would agree that was a wonderful
episode if you want to watch any other
trigonometry episodes they always go out
on wednesdays and sundays 7 p.m british
standard time 2 p.m eastern standard we
also do raw shows which go out tuesday
thursday friday saturday at the exact
same time thank you so much for tuning
in take care and see you soon guys hey
kkk do you like trigonometry yes do you
like live shows yes then you're going to
love the next trigonometry live show on
the 2nd of november at the leicester
square theatre in london it'll be with
one of our all-time favorite guests
peter hitchens this is very exciting
news i will make sure to take out an
advertisement in pravda tomorrow a fleet
of sponsored ladders will descend on the
kremlin to promote this wonderful event
our great and powerful leader uncle vlad
will be wearing sponsored trigonometry
speedos on white horse no nice mate our
first show with andrew doyle is now
completely sold out and this one will
sell out just as quickly tickets are
strictly limited and they're selling
like copies of the communist manifesto
greatest book in the world second only
to 10 cute things you didn't know about
joseph stalin i love that buzzfeed
article anyway see you there guys